[Captioned via Y Translator]
Today, we're going to take some
of this weirdly liquid,
weirdly solid Silly Putty,
and see if we can use it
as a mold for casting metal.
[Music]
YouTube user Kermit on Weed says,
"Now cast into silly putty."
This comment has
more thumbs up than
I think I've ever seen on one
of our videos at almost 2000.
Probably isn't 2000 by now.
So we're going to do that.
We've got a bunch of Silly Putty,
and we are going to try casting
molten metal in Silly Putty.
The premise is simple.
We're going to empty
out all of these eggs.
Smoosh all of the Silly Putty
together into a big blob,
press something into it,
to turn the Silly Putty into a mold,
and then try to fill that cavity
with two different types of molten metal.
Let's start opening these eggs.
I remember when I was an egg,
that's a lot of eggs.
It's gonna be a lot of silly putty.
[Music]
Well, this is the most Silly Putty
that I have ever had at once.
I'm gonna try and
squish this all into a ball.
I don't want to mix it,
because I kind of like
the separate colors,
but I do need to combine it.
It's all joined together pretty well,
now, I want to try
and roll it into a ball,
and see how it bounces.
[Music]
That kind of worked,
I made a ball.
It bounces.
[Music]
Oh, it's popping apart.
The seams are letting go,
probably just need to let
it sit for like an hour
to really bond everywhere,
but... I'm not going to do that right now.
So, let's try turning this into a mold
that we can cast molten metal in.
The first time we did this,
we used a 3D print of Grant's face.
Well today, we have a 3D print of my face,
and I think it's only fair that we try
doing the same thing with this.
[Music]
I thought our Silly Putty did
a really good job of taking
our impression of Mini-Me,
but unfortunately, Silly Putty
is not quite solid.
In fact, that's what's
kind of cool about it.
But in this case,
it meant that the Gallium,
which is quite heavy,
was just pressing down on it
as a liquid for a good amount of time.
The gallium was really barely
over its melting temperature,
but it takes quite a while
for it to fully solidify.
And in the time lapse,
you're able to see that it
just sort of smooshed everything down,
and eventually,
pushed the Silly Putty,
and broke free and spilled onto our table.
And so now what we have is this just
blob that really doesn't resemble
my face even a little bit.
Let's peel this up,
and see what kind of shapes we've got.
Okay, so we have the shape
of crystallized gallium.
It does form some cool
geometric looking shapes.
And that made a cool dent right
into our Silly Putty.
I don't see any remnant
of my face in that.
A nice smooth surface that once
again bears zero resemblance
to the sweatshirt that I had on here.
As casting goes,
I would say this is one
of our worst failures ever.
Zero resemblance,
like just none whatsoever
to what it was supposed to be.
Part of the problem of course was
that it took so long to solidify,
and so I think we now need to do
another test with a different metal,
and for that, we're
going to move onto aluminum.
So let's fire up our furnace,
melt some aluminum,
press this little face down
into the Silly Putty a second time,
and then pour some 2,000 degree
molten metal down into it
and see what happens to Silly Putty
under those conditions.
Guys, I gotta admit.
I am not very hopeful that this is
gonna turn out well in aluminum.
[Music]
Our aluminum is
melting already.
So we're now going to press
the little plastic mini me down
into the Silly Putty,
make a new mold,
pull out our molten aluminum,
pour it in and see how
the Silly Putty fares against
our very very hot aluminum.
[Music]
All right.
There's me.
Decent mold.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
That immediately lit on fire.
[Music]
I'm just gonna back off
a little bit in case
it decides to start
spurting aluminum.
It's on fire yo.
[Music]
Oh, the aluminum
is still molten.
[Music]
Our Silly Putty
is getting ruined.
Oh, we've got some good
drippage going on.
Silly Putty is melting
in some spots.
[Music]
The aluminum is still nice
and molten as well.
Our putty is melting.
It might break down the walls
that are holding in the aluminum.
We'll see.
I don't know if the aluminum is
quite liquid enough to run it.
So this is kind of interesting.
Our aluminum has now
been recovered in almost all
of it by the burning Silly Putty.
There's one spot here still exposed,
but there's actually sort
of a bubble over it.
Watch this.
[Music]
I can blow it out briefly,
and then the heat just
brings it right back.
[Music]
Our aluminum has
now cooled down.
[Music]
Well, I'm not going to say
that's a good casting,
but amazingly, it is a better
casting than the gallium.
Just did a fantastic job
of lighting our silly putty on fire,
and then just melting it.
Really nice and liquid,
and full of burnt Silly Putty ash here.
Nice little scoop
of hot Silly Putty.
I'm trying to see
if the Silly Putty that got melted,
so it was really runny.
We'll sort of reconstitute
as it cools down,
and return to normal Silly Putty.
So far it seems
like it is actually.
It's still very warm.
So it's a little softer
than it was before,
but it's acting pretty much how you
would expect Silly Putty to act.
I would say it looks
like you can melt
and resolidify Silly Putty,
as much as it ever gets solid,
which is of course, not much.
[Music]
Well, that didn't work,
and it smells bad.
Mmm...
Burning plasticky smell.
So not all of this silly putty is ruined,
but I don't think I can separate
the unruined Silly Putty
from the ruined Silly Putty.
So, for that reason,
this might all just be gone.
Casting metal into silly putty.
Thank you for your suggestion,
Kermit on weed.
As you can see,
it did not work.
We tried gallium, which is
like the coolest casting we can do,
and it still took so long
to completely solidify.
It just smooshed all
the silly putty out and ran,
and I do think this is probably
the worst casting we have ever got
off of anything.
No one would ever be able to look at that,
and guess that it was even supposed
to be a cast of a small person,
like a bust or anything like that.
The aluminum, also bad,
but I think many people
would at least look at that and say like,
oh that kind of looks like a deformed
outline of a human bust shape.
Like you can see there's a head,
and the shoulders,
and a little bit of the chest.
Whereas with the gallium,
there's just three puddles,
and some geometric
shapes that have formed in them.
None of which look anything
like little plastic me.
Thank you guys for sending
in your questions.
Now, it's time to give
you some answers.
All right, we've got a question here
from @Seth_Burrow, who is asking,
"Does Nate have his own Twitter handle,
or does he use
The King of Random Twitter handle?"
The real answer to this one
Seth is that I don't have Twitter.
I don't use Twitter.
I don't tweet.
I rarely read tweets,
and it's something that
I probably should get into.
But I think I tried it once
about four or five years ago,
and I realized I did not have
anything worth tweeting about.
So I just I tweeted like once,
and then I was like,
well, I don't know
why I'm doing this.
This is just like screaming
off the edge of a cliff,
and no one's listening,
and I didn't really see much point
in continuing to tweet in that situation.
Maybe now, I'm in a position where
more people would be interested
in what I'm doing, what I'm saying,
and especially if I were giving commentary
on some of the videos,
or some of the projects,
or some of my ideas,
or if I wanted to get more ideas,
so I should probably jump back on Twitter.
But at the moment,
I have no Twitter.
Sorry.
Guys, thanks for watching,
but that's not all.
That box up at the top
will take you directly
to our last video.
You should go
check that one out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you haven't subscribed yet,
just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way, you'll never
miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.